[Music]
keeping up with the kardashians fans
brace yourselves
we're about to get the episode we've all
been waiting for
surrounding the Tristan Thompson and
Jordan woods cheating scandal in a
teaser for next week's episode of
Keeping Up we see Chloe and her family
reacting to the news her boyfriend and
daughter trues father cheated on her
with her sister Kylie's best friend
Jordan Kim seems to be the one to break
the news to Chloe over the phone we also
see Kylie having a heart-to-heart with
her sisters about the situation you
could do whatever but when it affects
like my family that's when it's a
problem after the clip aired Chloe took
to Twitter to reveal she would not be
live-tweeting during the show next week
as usual writing well needless to say I
won't be live chatting next week sorry
guys genuinely I cannot believe that et
spoke with Coco's mom Kris Jenner in May
about how open her family is on the show
it's always difficult when somebody goes
through a rough time and I think one of
the things that has made the success of
the show is that you know show those
vulnerabilities and we're all so
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded and what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story
and they don't
[Music]